tiempo para la información económica en
france 24 para ello nos acompaña nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
y vamos a comenzar este repaso en el
continente asiático porque el repunte de
kobe en china amenaza la agitada
economía global así es y es que los
cierres en varias ciudades de china ya
están poniendo un poco más de presión a
las cadenas de suministro globales sobre
todo por el cierre de estas fábricas si
china no consigue contener este rebrote
con 19 peligro en sus buenas cifras de
crecimiento económico mostrada a inicios
de año y por consecuencia la economía
global podría verse en peligro en china
que es conocida como la fábrica del
mundo cualquier interrupción de las
exportaciones puede provocar un aumento
de los precios en un momento en que los
precios del consumidor de por sí ya
están por las nubes y obligan a los
bancos centrales a aumentar los tipos de
interés entre las ciudades que cerraron
por este brote esta shenzhen ubicada en
una provincia que es potencia
manufacturera para que nos demos una
idea su producto interno bruto de casi 2
billones de dólares aproximadamente el
de españa y corea del sur
de ahí se aporta el 11 por ciento
del producto interno bruto de la
economía china un informe del bank of
america corp mostró que la confianza en
el crecimiento mundial era la más baja
desde julio de 2008 y que las
expectativas de estanflación subieron al
62 por ciento según bloomberg según esta
misma publicación el cierre podría ser
más fuerte que el cierre nacional que
ocurrió al inicio de la pandemia en 2020
precisamente en wuhan china pues habrá
que estar muy atentos porque la economía
ya viene muy agitada y esto podría
todavía ponerlo peor vamos con los
precios del petróleo que ya están sobre
el 100 dólares y podrían impactar
también en los precios de los vuelos así
que esto lo dijo la asociación nacional
de transporte aéreo se advirtió que la
volatilidad de los precios van a
ocasionar un aumento de los precios de
los tiquetes de avión delta airlines y
su socio virgin atlantic dijeron que la
demanda como la de viajes
internacionales significaba que los
clientes estaban dispuestos a pagar
tarifas más altas las aerolíneas
estadounidenses no se protegen contra la
volatilidad de los precios del petróleo
como la mayoría de las aerolíneas en
europa esto podría aumentar los costos
principales en los viajes
un rubro que de por sí ya estaba de
cierta forma empujando la recuperación
post pandemia la guerra en ucrania ha
obligado al cierre también de amplias
zonas del espacio aéreo poniendo nuevas
presiones sobre el sector que lleva dos
años luchando contra las prohibiciones
de viaje- por el cob y 19 y seguimos
jorge con los precios del petróleo de
los combustibles al alza que ya han
provocado manifestaciones en todo el
mundo así que si empezamos en francia en
el oeste de francia donde un grupo de
manifestante bloquearon un depósito de
combustible en protesta por la subida de
precios en la ciudad de brest la
protesta fue liderada por pescadores y
trabajadores del sector de obras
públicas en colombo la principal ciudad
de ksir y la ncaa líderes opositores
lideraron manifestaciones por el aumento
de los precios de los alimentos y la
escasez de combustible el gobierno dijo
que se reunirá con el fondo monetario
internacional para obtener ayuda
económica y enfrentar esta situación
en filipinas varios conductores se
tomaron las calles de manila para exigir
al gobierno que tome acciones frente a
este aumento de los precios del
combustible
un impuesto especial al petróleo en
américa latina' en paraguay se vivió la
segunda jornada de bloqueos de
camioneros y conductores que exigen una
reducción en el precio de los
combustibles los manifestantes rechazan
la propuesta del gobierno de aplicar
rebajas en los carburantes que adquieran
en la estatal petróleos paraguayos y
ante todo este aumento de precios que
dicen los países exportadores así que
bueno este martes los países miembros de
la opep como se conoce el grupo del agua
la asociación de países exportadores
emitió un informe donde dicen que no
pueden prever la evolución económica
mundial por la alta incertidumbre según
esta organización las proyecciones sobre
la economía mundial cambian casi a
diario por lo que es difícil fijar una
sola cifra con un grado razonable de
certeza asimismo dejaron bajo revisión
la previsión sobre la demanda mundial de
crudo para este año de 100,9 millones de
barriles diarios este informe revela que
los países tienen dificultad para
aumentar de forma rápida su oferta
petrolera en caso de que se produzca un
corte de los suministros rusos
actual es aumentar el bombeo en 400 mil
barriles diarios cada mes pero este plan
ha probado mediados del año pasado no ha
sido posible pese al llamado de varios
países del mundo bueno jorge desde luego
el alza de los precios de los
combustibles está desbaratando toda la
economía a nivel mundial muchísimas
gracias por este repaso y a los
espectadores les invitamos a que sigan
conectados en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]